guten abend aus davos herzlich
willkommen zu unserem zweiten fasnet
videobericht vom weltwirtschaftsforum ja
heute waren die ersten bekannteren gäste
da unter anderem der neue präsident
brasiliens hervor so naro auf seinem
ersten offiziellen besuch bei einem bei
einer veranstaltung die vergleichbar ist
mit ebendiesem weltwirtschaftsforum
also es war sozusagen sein sein
internationales coming out und liebers
wenn was ist dein erster eindruck davon
ja lieber kassen du sagst es war sein
erster auftritt im ausland überhaupt
noch aufzuarbeiten reise und man hat
eigentlich gedacht jetzt kommt noch ein
bisschen was konkret ist aber es wirkt
doch sehr enttäuschend es kam eigentlich
inhaltlich sehr wenig rüber ball so nahe
rollers vom blatt ab und ja die äußerung
der tat waren eigentlich ein bisschen
hätten auch vom brasilianischen
touristik institute kommen können oder
also erwarte für besucher in seiner
heimat und für investitionen von dem
ball so naro den wir aus den medien
wahrgenommen haben er provoziert hat ist
relativ wenig über gekommen also
eigentlich ein tor schoss
ja was hat er gesagt hat gesagt dass
brasilien ein schönes land ist mit den
größten wäldern dieser welt und dass man
tolle küsten hat und tolle strände und
das viel viel mehr touristen kommen
sollen
das land soll sicher werden er will die
korruption bekämpfen der fahrer einen
minister dabei sogar so genau also viel
mehr ist bei mir auch wirklich nicht
hängen geblieben carsten es ist glaube
ich schon zu erwarten hat ja auch einen
minister ehemaligen investmentbanker der
die wirtschaft richten soll
und es ist zu erwarten dass ein kabinett
eine stark aus führende rolle spielen
will
er wird ja oft verglichen oder es gibt
die analogie der tram brasiliens wird
man donald trump im vergangenen jahr
hier gesehen hat kann man sagen diese
auftritte hatten wirklich überhaupt
nichts gemein
dennoch rampe dieses jahr aber nicht da
sein kassen last auch die schalte von
herrn pompeo angeschaut das wurde ja vor
betont vom wef dass es ganz selten nur
mal eine live-schalte gibt werde ich
nach davos kommt der hat auch nicht das
rechte und aufzutreten
in diesem fall wurde die ausnahme
gemacht für den amerikanischen
außenminister was war dein eindruck
er hat die gelegenheit genutzt einfach
nochmal seine bekannten standpunkte wenn
man so will vorzutragen ja dass die
rückbesinnung auf einen gesunden
nationalismus eine gute sache ist dass
grenzen geschützt werden müssen
das internationale organisation einfach
nicht das liefern was man von ihnen
verlangt dass amerika aber überhaupt
nicht irgendwie vorhat sich zu isolieren
sondern weiterhin selbstverständlich mit
partnern zusammenarbeitet die halt gute
deals mit ihnen abschließen mit den
chinesen laufen ja die gespräche mit den
koreanern da hat er den status quo
beschrieben aber breaking news machen da
auch nicht dabei also würde ich sagen
morgen geht's weiter morgen kommen die
bundeskanzlerin unter anderem was
erwartest du morgen worauf freust du
dich also ich bin ja vor allen dingen
für die it und software themen hier und
ich freue mich auf gespräche mit mit
amazon und google die heute abend noch
stattfinden und morgen auch noch mal
microsoft chef satya nadella eine
veranstaltung über japan
und wie die in dieses neue komplett
durch digitalisierte zeitalter starten
wollen
und da ist schon interessant interessant
zu hören wie europa hinten ansteht bei
vielen dingen und da mache ich mir im
moment viele gedanken zu wie das
vielleicht mal besser werden könnte das
können wir dann morgen oder übermorgen
besprechen liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer
schön dass sie auch heute wieder dabei
waren wir bleiben weiter für sie hier am
ball
bis bald